[Musik]
frühstück die wichtigste mahlzeit des
tages
ich finde heute könntet ihr verbraucher
euch mal bei uns lobbyisten bedanken
wir sorgen nämlich unermüdlich für
billig haba haba denn warum sind
lebensmittel bei uns so billig weil wir
bestimmen wie lebensmittel produziert
werden
hier kann sie auch wissen wie es jetzt
schon schlecht hier in berlin um die
ecke vom kanzleramt sitzt der deutsche
bauernverband die mächtigste lobby
gruppe von allen alter die bauern sind
so bambus wenn der bauernverband in der
hut ist wechseln libanesische gangster
die straßenseite wo ich mein fehler
olé olé super bauern mit dem wir zu
recht kein ärger haben fast nirgendwo in
der eu ist fressen so günstig wie in
deutschland von 10 euro einkommen gibt
der deutsche gerade mal im schnitt einen
euro für essen aus und alle helfen
sparen schon die tiere in einem
deutschen groß- mastbetriebs hat eines
auch weniger als einen quadratmeter
wohnfläche
das heißt auch dass wir in diesem
wunderschönen fahrzeug neun bis elf
schweine halten können fünf euro gewinn
kleinbauern schwein übrig und
geschlachtet und geschreddert wird dann
von rumänen und bulgaren für weniger als
einen euro pro tier
der anfang der nahrungskette ist das
schön hier
na gut der wille der stadt ist nicht
auszuhalten aber vielleicht wurst für
zehn cent das kilo gibt es halt nur mit
massentierhaltung viele tiere gleich
viel scheiße viel scheiße gleich viel
dünger viel dünner gleich viel futter
und dadurch wieder die tiere muss sockel
auf live alles ganz natürlich ich habe
schon als kind doch angst in einen käfig
gehalten
die sind halt gesellig und schmecken gar
nicht schlecht jetzt mal ehrlich warum
ist es hier draußen so schön weil die
ganzen stinkenden fischer alle drin im
stall stehen
warte mal da fällt mit sein
[Musik]
ich habe noch eine wahnsinns geschichte
kommen schwein zum arzt sagt herr doktor
ich habe hier überall ekligen ausschlag
ich glaube das kommt von der
massentierhaltung sorgte man kein
kopftuch bei dir se alles wurst
ich weiß mich weg leute wie sagt der
türke kühle gülle so freunde wenn ihr
das nächste mal ein doppelzentner
fleischkäse für eure kinder kauft denkt
immer daran es ist nur so billig weil
wir von der lobby für euch da sind er
braucht jetzt nicht danke sagen ich
mache nur meinen job so wir fangen jetzt
erst mal die amtierende
landwirtschaftsministerin ins büro und
schwingt die hufe muss arbeiten und
deshalb von den grünen irgendwas von
tierschutz hat schweinefleisch stand
kopf
[Musik]